The Joe Rogan experience.
I had a thought once while I was under the influence and it was um,
a thought that one day computational powers will reach a point where they will
be able to take into consideration all of the objects on earth and what we know
about the history and vividly recreate the past through,
through computation to the point where you could actually know who did what when
people did things.
And that,
I mean,
I don't even know if this would be physical today,
certainly not be possible,
but with the exponential increase in computational power and technology and
innovation that one day we'll reach a point where you'll be able to watch,
you'll be able to see what happened and they'll be able to recreate what
happened exactly.
And that this would be something that would be,
it's impossible for us to imagine that someone would be able to do that right
now.
Yeah.
But that one day with technology as it gets more and more advanced and we will
reach some sort of,
uh,
some innovation or some sort of an invention that will allow us to go back and
see,
literally see what,
what happened,
how things were done.
Tech technologies is changing.
Our whole understanding of the past and what you're envisaging is perfectly
possible.
We will,
we will come to a time,
if the hundred years,
$500 less,
if we don't,
you know,
first destroy ourselves entirely as a civilization.
We will come to a time where our cleverness and our techniques will allow a much
wider opening up of the past then has presently happened,
but it is already happening.
Um,
one of the areas of science that I go into in America before his genetics,
uh,
and,
and DNA,
uh,
this is an area of science that sa was not much informing archeology until about
the 1990s,
but since the two thousands has become very important in archeology because the
technology has been developed where ancient DNA can be extracted and tested,
and you can actually genotype an entire individual from DNA that may be 15,
20,000,
20,000 years old.
Um,
and this,
uh,
new technology of genome sequencing and DNA is another factor that is raising
huge question marks over the past of the Americas.
And one of the issues I go into a in this book is the presence in the Amazon
rainforest of a very specific,
clearly identifiable pattern of DNA,
which is only found in one other place in the world.
And that is in Australasia,
uh,
in Papua New Guinea and amongst Australian aborigines,
it's Australasian Dna.
Uh,
now South American,
not only in South America,
but in the depths of the Amazon rainforest amongst tribes who have only been
contacted in the last 20 or 30 years.
Uh,
and further more,
although skeletal remains are rare,
it has been found in ancient skeletal remains that are close to 11,000 years old
in the Amazon.
So that tells us that this DNA signal has been in the Amazon for at least 11,000
years.
The geneticists think that it came to the Amazon during the last ice age and
this raises a huge mystery because the peopling of the Americas is supposed to
have occurred from Siberia across the Bering Straits,
down through that ice free corridor into North America,
down through North America,
into South America,
into Central America,
and finally into South America.
If that was the whole story,
then we would find this DNA signal in North America and in Central America.
We would not find it only in the Amazon.
When I talked to some of the leading geneticists about this,
but specifically,
um,
sq.
Professor Sk Willis live at the University of Copenhagen,
there's been the lead author in a number of major studies of Ancient Dna.
And I asked him,
what do you make of this Australasia in DNA,
uh,
in,
in the Amazon?
And he said,
honestly,
we don't have a proper explanation for it at at the moment.
But what he did say is that the most parsimonious explanation,
he used that specific word,
the most parsimonious explanation is that a group of people during the ice age
crossed the Pacific Ocean and settled up and ended up in South America and
settled in the Amazon and brought their DNA with them.
That would account perfectly for the DNA data.
And when a scientist says the most parsimonious explanation,
what that scientist is saying is he likes that explanation that it's a simple,
direct,
clear explanation of the DNA mystery.
But then he added however,
it doesn't make practical sense.
And I asked him,
well,
why doesn't it make practical sense?
And he said,
because the archeologists tell me that no human population was capable of
crossing the Pacific Ocean during the Ice Age,
at which point it was natural for me to say,
do you really trust the archeologists?
And he said,
well,
in science we do trust the work of other scientists.
We don't really question it,
we don't really investigate it.
That's their side of the,
their side of the business.
Um,
and,
and my,
my view is that that is rather than rather than excel,
rather than taking this weird anomalous Australasia and DNA signal,
uh,
in the,
in,
in the heart of the Amazon as something to be explained away and there's
something to be for it to be denied,
that it could be connected to a voyage across the Pacific Ocean.
Maybe it's the first compelling evidence that voyages were taking place across
the Pacific Ocean during the ice age.
And maybe we should be opening up that whole issue for exploration.
And again,
I think I lost a lost civilization is the best answer.
And that near the end of the ice age when,
when the younger dryas cataclysm unfolds,
it's not an overnight thing.
It's very bad.
12,000,
800 years ago,
there's about 1000 hundred years of horror.
I don't think the civilization went down in a single day and night.
I think there were survivors,
I think bits of it were left.
I think that project was to restart civilization.
And I suggest very strongly that where they tried to mount that project was
amongst the hunter gatherers who coexisted in the world with them at that time.
We ourselves are an advanced civilization,
at least that's what we call ourselves and we coexist in the world with hunter
gatherers.
Uh,
it's not an odd idea that an advanced civilization,
a hunter gatherers should coexist and there is separation between us and the
Amazonian hunter gatherers.
There are tribes in the Amazon that are uncontacted and that we,
that we don't know even exist if catastrophe on the level of the younger drivers
were to occur today.
I don't think that our civilization would make it through.
We are the spoiled children of the earth.
We are just used to having everything laid on,
you know,
the supermarket shelves are groaning with,
with food.
We can get food delivered to our homes.
We have roofs over our head,
we have shelters,
we have coding.
Everything is taken for granted.
I guess you're an exception,
but very few people in modern western culture know how to survive.
They don't have survival skills.
They don't know how to hunt.
They don't know how to gather.
They don't know how to grow crops because they've handed that responsibility
over to others.
We live in a society that's highly segmented and specialized in different people
specialize in different things,
but nobody has the vast general survival skill that a hunter gatherer has.
So in a global cataclysm,
actually at first counter,
intuitively the people who would survive it would be the hunter gatherers and an
advanced civilization would be smart if they were survivors to seek refuge
amongst hunter gatherers,
uh,
to,
to make that the place where they might try to start,
restart their civilization.
And that's why I think that this Austria Lazy and DNA signal in the Amazon may
be part of the evidence for a sort of outreach effort that was being made by a
lost civilization.
Seeing the disaster coming down on it and realizing that something needed to be
done.